hello salutations ed good morning
everybody
or a terrible morning so remember the
last video i talked about the california
wildfires well it actually didn't get
any
better from yesterday it actually got
worse so this fire right now
is zero percent contained
zero percent now we've had a lot of
california wildfires before specifically
in california since the drought
whenever it's super dry season there's a
high chance that there's going to be a
fire but this is probably the biggest
fire that los angeles has ever faced
and it started from somebody exploding
some [ __ ] for a gender reveal party they
thought that pyrotechnics would be good
on the
hottest [ __ ] day la has
ever experienced i think i spit into the
camera
with all the lights off if i look
outside my window of the office if i
look outside of the window in the
kitchen
and especially in the backyard it looks
insane
maybe it's gonna be okay
mommy just made a mistake
i think we should have a party
it's 118 degrees
what's the worst that could happen
[Music]
so if you guys don't know about the
history of the gender reveal party
apparently
it happened because a lady was going to
have a child and
in her family she had a nephew that was
born so her family spent
all their excitement juice on the nephew
and when her kid was born
she felt that you know the family didn't
give a [ __ ] as much so she was like
okay well fine i'm gonna have a gender
reveal party
just to make myself feel better and now
she regrets it because
the thing that she created caused all
the world to burn hey
you're not going to hell you are i am
legit outside of my apartment right now
and that's my truck if you guys just saw
when i swipe my hand
uh there is a [ __ ] ton of ash on it
and i don't even know right now if it
does justice on the camera to see how
bleak and dark it is
but just if you look out maybe 10 or 15
feet in front of you
it's a it's a cloudy polluted haze it's
super hard to breathe right now i'm
telling you all these people who are
anti-massacres i'll bet you ain't no
anti-massacre now son
i know for a fact this video was not
doing it any justice but i
really wish i could show you guys this
stuff it's just saying i'm looking for
the sun
but the other day when i was looking at
the sun it was just bright orange
because of all the pollution we gotta
protect
our earth people also stop who the [ __ ]
cares
about the gender of your baby i said it
i i could give a [ __ ] less boy or girl
just be happy that you have a healthy
child then
in the car waiting for the boys to show
up today is going to be another podcast
with nick and oh [ __ ] i didn't even park
the car
i could have killed myself look at nick
and his stupid ugly face
and his stupid car i'm going to confront
him
look who we have here dude
you guys can't see this but most people
when they vlog they have you know small
little tiny gopros
this dude is filming with a red camera
no
i need you to understand hey bro hey uh
i'm just vlogging here he's literally
kidding
guys i'm just here casually did you
really eat that cookie off the floor
i did eat that cookout disgusting dude
you know everybody hates you because you
had a cookie off the floor now hey man
or people respect me more
oh what the [ __ ] would they respect
that's a man of values that's a man of
convictions
you know and now what's the conviction
though tell me what the conviction is
just i i made a decision in my head and
i stood but i stood by
frank went out to get the cookie for you
you little [ __ ]
because you couldn't do it yourself
because you knew it was wrong
[Music]
here we have oh the [ __ ] mic is in
your face you you tried the head on you
right now
i just hit on the vlog
we got pat here uh in the podcast room
showed up a little later than expected
and of course this guy who doesn't drink
is holding this liquor bottle for no
goddamn reason
ultra 100 the agave
and then uh what's unhit and hail bro
take a shot for the vlog
no bro i mean a [ __ ]
oh yeah i'm not a [ __ ] i'll take a shot
right now dude do it right now bro start
right now
show me right now bro no our video's
gonna be demonetized for no reason oh
it's already
monetized because of those ears it's
just it's dangerous
and then we're like all right bro relax
just say you don't have a cup and then
his daughter comes up to him and she
goes
it's okay daddy yeah you'll get him next
time hold his hand
takes him away so we just found out and
you guys will see it on the podcast
that pat has a boxing match coming up
with
heart very very good friend chris sosa
man
and i'm preparing my drinking tequila
and that's his coach
first day of fight camp this is his
recommendation
six grams of uh protein yeah in uh every
serving of alcohol you didn't tell them
that chris's dad is a really famous
boxing coach out in houston and he owns
his own so chris's dad is a very famous
boxing coach that owns this oh that's
really great
yeah he trains a lot of pros and stuff
like that and uh chris has had like 60
amateur fights
wow just found that out just today right
now and he already agreed to me
i know i thought he couldn't tell me the
[ __ ] he did not know that he just found
out right now yeah i didn't know that i
thought you knew that i know you had 60
[ __ ] fights
i'm scared now well guys
this is fine this is the new podcast
room i actually haven't shown you guys
the new podcast room but if you take a
look around
we have china ball lighting let me let
me take them let me take them i'll just
take them along
oh show them please please please this
is about 80 pounds anyways go ahead do
it right
so this is um hey guys i'm going to give
you a quick i just press
well back in the podcast or the editing
room
as it is as you can see that the footage
is missing i don't know where i placed
it
[ __ ] me right hilarious podcast as
always love
those two dudes find yourself people
that can always make you laugh
and just talk about dumb [ __ ] i feel a
lot of the times when we find friends or
we're trying to connect with people you
guys always think that you need to have
a deep conversation about everything
you really don't sometimes you just need
to be around people that just
say stupid [ __ ] and we have an
assortment of pepsi because we don't
drink
coca-cola it's assortment of pepsi it's
not just one pepsi
it's literally the same pepsi can over
and over i'm still getting a grasp of
the english language
but afterwards to end a great podcast we
went to go eat some tacos
at the spot really close to the office
and this spot too i wanted to feature
them but
the customer service there is absolutely
terrible and most of the time when i do
reviews for places i don't really do
yelp reviews anymore
but if i am going to feature a spot you
know i want people to have a good
experience the tacos here are pretty
good they're like tijuana style street
tacos
but this is where i'll be spending most
of my days the world is burning outside
listen
i don't want to say gender reveal
parties are stupid because i want people
to enjoy what they're doing if you want
to celebrate
certain monumentous moments of your life
please go ahead i don't know man it
feels like i'm living in a black
mirror world where i don't know if
people genuinely do things
to do things because they enjoy are they
doing it now just to be recognized to be
noticed or maybe this is how it's always
been
but gender reveal parties for me feel
like you're just doing it for the gram
and you want people to notice you i
don't know i could be a hater
maybe one day when i get pregnant i mean
[Music]
i make no apologies enjoy that clip
you're welcome for the nightmares